hi i'm katie and i'm a tasty producer
when i started here i was actually
making a lot of the top down recipe
videos and
what we do is we cram like an entire
recipe that might take
30 minutes or even half a day into like
30 seconds or a minute
so today i'm gonna watch one of those
old tasty videos that i don't know which
one it's gonna be
and i'm gonna try to make it the twist
is i can only watch it one time i feel
like i have a really good memory but
it's been a long time since it's been
put to the test so i could be a bit
rusty i'm still a little afraid because
those videos go so fast
oh okay a caramel apple upside down cake
i wonder
whose recipe this is it's alvin's recipe
so we know it's gonna be good but we
also know it might be like a little
complicated
i'm gonna have to really look at these
amounts ready set
go sugar a third cup oh god baking
powder okay two eggs two eggs two eggs a
third cup of oil a third cup of milk
okay we've got and he's just doing all
in one bowl so that's good vanilla
didn't see how much that's okay
okay now we are on to making the caramel
i didn't see how much butter
a cup of caramel oh so he uses like
pre-caramel sauce with the butter
that makes my life easier and then he
sliced i think this is a granny smith
apples
and he's gonna bake that for 25 minutes
oh at 3 25
i think and great and that was 25
minutes was that 25 minutes
guys i already forget i'll just keep
checking it in the oven i feel good but
like there's a lot of numbers in my head
right now like was it a cup and a
quarter of flour was it a cup and a half
of flour it's gonna be interesting some
things i'm worried about is if i don't
cook it at the right time like that
caramel at the bottom could burn
because it's an upside down cake they're
like a little bit spongier and springier
getting those ratios right oh my god was
it two eggs or three
i don't remember all right
i am about to embark on this experiment
i'm gonna be making the cake
first i've pretty much forgotten most of
the things i watched but i do remember
the steps so the first thing i'm going
to start with is the cake remember at
the beginning i was like it's a cup and
a half or a cup and a quarter of flour
cup and a half of flour so remember that
guys i'm gonna go with a cup and a half
you don't really want to get the flour
wrong though because if you put too much
flour it's going to be like a
super dry dense cake a lot of times when
you make a cake you will like do your
dry ingredients in one bowl and your wet
ingredients but this goes all in one
bowl which is helpful so i'm just gonna
build from what i remember
it's probably not in the order of the
video i don't oh no one look
nobody look at this i think a half a cup
of sugar sounds good
i don't remember how much sugar i think
we're gonna do some baking powder i see
it here
this is gonna help the cake rise again i
don't remember but a lot of times it's a
teaspoon or like a half a teaspoon
okay now there was the oil i think it
was a third cup
oil and a third cup milk i think it was
about the same ratios oh
salt was there any salt did he not have
salt in this recipe
alvin tisk tisk i don't think there was
any salt so
usually i'd add salt i'm not going to
okay so a third cup of oil
it's a little one to one ratio there and
then there was eggs and guys
i really cannot remember if it was two
to three eggs
two eggs two eggs two eggs the eggs are
what kind of help bind everything
together
it makes it moist it makes it spongy i'm
not a pastry chef but
too many eggs i think can make it like
too dense like just be like a rubbery
too rubbery
and then like too few and it can be
really delicate but i don't think we're
gonna go wrong
with three eggs i'm gonna do
three eggs all right choices made it's
like i always make the wrong choice
i think that's everything that goes into
our batter
i'm going to kind of make a judgment if
i need to add more of anything once we
see like the texture of my batter
because
the batter in the video was like very
smooth and like almost a little ribbony
and mine is looking like a little clumpy
oh god i don't think i should have put
that other egg or did i put too much
flour
i'm second-guessing everything i'm doing
here i'm gonna add a little more milk
guys i hope this tastes good all right
this is looking more of the consistency
of the video okay so this is like what
i'm talking about that more ribbony
texture
it's a little smoother no regrets okay
batter is done
boom now we gotta make that caramel
[Music]
so now that we've made the batter which
i'm very scared of now we're gonna be
making
the caramel and this part i'm feeling a
little less nervous about because
we're not making it from scratch we are
going to use dulce de leche which is
like the milk based caramel it's already
made for us
he cut up the butter but this also is
going to have like a lot of
fat and stuff in it so i don't think i'm
going to need to add too much to it
so maybe i'll start with a half of a
half a cup so a quarter cup of butter
and i think he cut it up into pieces so
it melted evenly and quickly
it was in pieces right guys memories
they're crazy
hmm did he do a whole stick of butter
that's a lot of butter if he did a whole
stick
let's see what this looks like when it
melts you know what butter makes
everything better so
i don't think it's gonna hurt if i just
add a little more i'm gonna just think
that he used
all of this right now i'm worried i may
have done too much butter just because
it's like kind of splitting
with the caramel you can kind of see the
fat like pulling away from it but i
think if i
stir fast and this melts more maybe it
will incorporate the butter better okay
okay so see now it's all mixed together
so i think we're okay
our caramel looks good it's coming
together i'm not feeling as scared as i
was
and while it's still hot i'm gonna pour
this into
our baking pan here while it's still
pretty warm i want to cut these apples
and get them in
it didn't read how many apples so i
guess i didn't get any of the numbers i
only saw steps so
i'm just going to cut as many apples and
i'll just start filling up this pan
and that should be fine were they
skinned who likes skin on their apple
i don't remember we're gonna commit to
this
so it might be a little thin but that's
all right it does remind me of like
being
in like finals you know when you can see
the textbook page
and you can see the photo that's there
and you know the answers like in the
third paragraph
but like you just can't read the
paragraph from your memory and like if
you just could you would know that's how
i feel right now i think this looks
pretty with the overlapping like you
know if you didn't overlap maybe you
should have overlapped that's what i'm
gonna say with so much confidence
okay i'm not sure how he tackled this
inner circle but i think i'm just gonna
overlap them again this is it once i put
this in no
altering it yeah his batter was
definitely like a little bit
runnier than mine slam it down make sure
it gets evenly distributed
okay i should have been preheating this
while i was making this cake
i'm gonna get the oven i think that it
said 325.
350 is pretty standard for baking i'm
going to go like the little lower
and slower to see so it doesn't over
bake and i think it said 25 minutes so
i'm going to wait for this to heat up
and i'm going to check it in 15
probably moment of truth big deal
we'll see how it comes out so now i'm
starting to worry that
i thought it was 3 25 because i saw 25
minutes to bake
when i looked at it in 15 minutes it was
still really like
not cooked so i've added 10 more minutes
we're going to get to the 25.
i think it's going to be okay but i
think it's definitely going to take
longer now than 25 minutes
i think it should have been 350.
so i've taken the cake out of the oven
after extensive checking on it
but i think i could have maybe over
baked it i don't know right now it's
giving me like pancake vibes i feel like
it might be a dry
cake let's see i'm gonna try to do the
flip reveal right now
okay well what i can see
is that some of our our caramel burned a
little and maybe it's because i didn't
add
maybe i added too much butter so we are
also missing
some apples that got stuck up in our
caramel usually with an upside down cake
this caramel
is just like super luscious and runny
and just like dripping off and this
caramel is
really thick i'm gonna take a photo and
see
see what alvin thinks i today
guys what's happening
i definitely added an ellipses to that
because you know it's like
i don't want him to think that i thought
this turned out great so the cake did
not turn out as pretty as one would hope
but let's see how it tastes now
the cake is good it's not great it's not
as like spongy and light as i would have
liked it to be
what i do like about what i did is i
like how thin i cut my apples because
it's a nice little crunch
overall the cake is also not too sweet
which is good because you have this
caramel you have the ice cream so i like
the sweetness let's look at what the
actual recipe is
so the first line of it says preheat the
oven at 350 degrees
already starting off bad i did 325 it
was one and a half cup flour so i did
that right it was a third cup sugar
so it's a little less sugar in the cake
i think half cup is good then you add
eggs which is two eggs then it was a
third cup oil
and a third cup milk so i did that right
it was a tablespoon of vanilla
extract okay well i completely forgot
about vanilla extract maybe that's also
why it's feeling like it's just missing
like a little something
and then we move on to making the
caramel where you put the dill chili de
leche
with two tablespoons of butter and then
he
used three granny smith apples i used
one if i was to give my cake a rating
i'd give it like a seventy percent it's
still passing but it's almost a fail
it's like if someone gave it to me i'd
be like okay
my advice to you guys would be just read
the recipe don't do this
[Music]
you